This is an example,
or rather, a story,
that's supposed to
give us some insight
and some intuition
about what the law
of iterated expectations
really means.
Suppose that you work for
a forecasting company.
And suppose that
you make forecasts
by calculating expected
values of the quantities
that you want to forecast.
And of course, when you
calculate an expected value,
you always use whatever
information you have.
So here we have the
beginning of the year.
And you're working
for a company that's
trying to forecast the sales
during the month of February.
That's a random
variable, capital
X. You're sitting in your office
in the beginning of the year.
What is going to
be your forecast?
It's going to be the expected
value of the random variable X.
So this is a forecast that you
make at this point in time.
Now, time goes by,
and we're sitting now
in the beginning of February
or the end of January.
At that time, you obtain
some new information,
which is the value, little y,
of a random variable, capital
Y. What should your
new forecast be?
Well, once you have this
information in your hands,
your new forecast should
be the expected value
of x, given the specific
available information
that you have.
So this is the
revised forecast as
calculated at the
end of January.
But if you're sitting here
in the beginning of the year
and you ask yourself, what
is the revised forecast going
to be, your answer
would be, I don't
know what it's going to be.
It's random.
It depends on what capital
Y would end up being.
My revised forecast is a random
variable, the expected value
of X given Y, which will take
this particular numerical value
if it turns out the
random variable Y
takes a specific
value, little y.
So this is the
forecast calculated
at this point in time.
This is the forecast
viewed at the beginning
of the year, at which
time we do not know yet
the value of the
revised forecast.
Now, what does the law
of iterated expectations
tell us in this case?
It tells us that the expected
value of the revised forecast
is the same as the
original forecast.
What does this mean
in practical terms?
It means that given
today's forecast,
the original
forecast, you do not
expect the next
forecast, the revised
one, to be higher or lower.
It could be either
higher or lower.
But on the average,
you expect the revision
of the forecast going
from this one to that one,
the revised one, that
revision on the average,
to be equal to 0.
You do not expect forecasts
to be revised either upwards
or downwards on the average.
Of course, this is not what
happens always in real life.
So suppose that capital X, the
quantity you're forecasting,
is the cost of some big project.
And your original budget
or original forecast,
expected value of X,
is what you expect
the cost of the project to be.
Well, from experience
with real life,
we kind of know that
budgets or cost estimates
tend to be revised upwards
more often than downwards.
Does this real life
fact contradict
the law of iterated
expectations?
Well, not really.
What is going on here is that
real life forecasts are not
really honestly calculated
expected values.
But maybe they're calculated
with some implicit or hidden
biases so that the
forecasts that are given
are actually not
the expected values.
So there's no contradiction
between this mathematical fact
and possible life experiences.